joining me now is congressman Jim Jordan
ranking member of the House Oversight
Committee congressman since the media
are not going to search for new leads
you know it's left to folks like you
okay one of the facts missing thus far
is what did the actual requests for
unmasking say it's because I'm asking is
not illegal and these people have the
authority to do that but what did the
request for unmasking actually say by
all those individuals who filed them yes
against Flynn yeah what was their reason
and why so many people and why all in
this interesting time and as you just
pointed out Laura the media was
cheerleaders for this entire effort and
their cheerleading took place at
interesting times as well think about
January of 2017 during the transition on
the 4th of January
you got you got Peter struck telling the
agents hey don't drop the case against
Flynn keep it up Comey told me to told
me to tell you to keep pursuing Mike
Flynn the next day Comey meets with
President Obama in the Oval Office and
talks about Mike Flynn January 6 Comey
goes up to New York and briefs President
Trump on the dossier he already knows
his false misleading and paid for by the
Clinton campaign and yet briefs month
and then that leaks the dossier that the
fact that he had that conversation and
then the leak you pointed out January
12th David Ignatius of story leaks and
then what did they do on the 24th of
January Jim Comey sends two agents
sneaks them into the White House to set
up Michael Flynn that Ignatius story
helped all that play out so they're
cheerleaders not just in a general sense
for the left and for the Democrats
they're cheerleaders at interesting
times in the sequence of events so those
are the kind of things we need to get
answers to yeah well in in as someone
said earlier today came over what I was
watching but it was like the the
journalists become participants in the
ongoing saga to try to kneecap Trump or
take out one of his top people to then
kneecap Trump so they become
participants rather than curious
aggressive journalists who say well why
is that being leaked to me maybe there's
a deeper story here what's your
motivation and leaking to me instead
just repeating it and running with it
and you know
being a liberal reporter means never
having to say you're sorry right right
and they should have to say that because
remember what the president said he said
they spied on our campaign he said this
is not true there was no collusion
between anything our campaign - anything
I did in Russia he said those things and
of course he was and he said this whole
thing was a witch-hunt and now after all
these facts come out we see exactly that
each of those three statements behind
the president has proven to be true and
yet they just keep on going with their
narrative because they're so determined
to go after this president you know this
this is it this is a simple principle
here when you drain the swamp the swamp
fights back even even when they know
they're wrong and even when it's proven
they're wrong they keep fighting back
yeah last night during Ingraham angle
exclusive John Solomon reported that
Murray Ivanovich omitted mentioning her
burry smih meetings during her
impeachment testimony you sent a letter
to Pompeo about this tell us more very
quickly about 30 seconds well what she
said in the deposition what she said
when she testified in the impeachment
hearing is different than what the
documents seemed to reveal and I give
Lee Zeldin a tremendous amount of credit
because he pushed her during the
deposition got her to say that all it
was just a briefing I got when I was
getting ready for my confirmation but it
turns out she talked about barrese me
and Hunter Biden a lot more than she
indicated we want to see the documents
unredacted so we can get a better and
closer look at what really took place
here all right well we're talking about
the lion ization of whistleblowers and
people related to whistleblowers and
that story fits right in with it
congressman thanks so much that thanks
Laura